- This story made headlines
and a local UPS delivery man named Hector,
he took the time to stop and
brighten a young boys day.
Take a look.
- Hi drew.
We're excited to tell you about a person
who's made a very special impact
on our family during COVID.
Our UPS delivery man, Hector.
We have a four year old
son who's been lonely
and cooped up inside,
and gets very excited
when he hears the garbage man come by,
the mailman, but especially Hector.
- I like Hector when he plays his music
and drives by my house.
I love playing with trucks.
- One day when Hector
was delivering packages,
Langston stopped him and asked him,
Hey, do you have any packages for me?
Hector to give them the bad news
and said, no, I don't
have any packages for you,
but maybe tomorrow, maybe
you'll get a package.
- So the next day
Langston heard him coming,
he ran outside shrieking
and squealing in excitement.
When Hector pulled his truck up,
he came up the stairs
and handed Langston a box special for him.
- Hector gave me a box
full of toys and trucks.
Hector is my friend.
- Such an amazing act of kindness
on Hector's part to be
going from his busy day
and still be able to
see and notice our son.
This little act of kindness
has just really gone a long way
and it keeps paying forward.
- [All Three] Thank you
Hector, we love you.
(clapping)
- Oh, I just, I love this so much.
Hector, what made you?
Hi Hector, how are you?
- Hi, hi Drew.
Nice to meet you.
- Okay, you're so rad.
- I'm good.
Thank you so much for coming on the show.
Hector, what-
- Thank you for having me.
- Oh God, we are just talking
right over each other.
I am so sorry.
I'm going to ask you a
question and then shut up.
Hang on, check this out.
What, how did you notice Langston?
Like what was it that made you clock him?
- Well, I had noticed
Langston two weeks prior.
I saw him in his little balcony.
I would say hi to him.
I would wave at him.
I'd be like, Hey, or like
hi, or nod, you know,
because I'm always busy running around.
And I noticed him that one time
when I delivered to his neighbor
and as I go upstairs,
deliver to the neighbor,
and then I see him, and
then he looks at me,
and I kind of noticed that he noticed
that I wasn't going to give him a package,
and he just put his little arm,
and so like, Oh, I want one too, you know?
And that's how I noticed though.
- Well, how did you know what would make-
- It kind of like-
- Langston smile?
How did you know what to get him?
- Well, I've always had toys
or action figures for boys,
you know 'cause you know,
I've always wanted a boy,
but you know, we never had one.
I have two daughters, which is awesome,
but I told my wife, I go, you know what?
These little toys that I've had.
I go, I think I know somebody
who would appreciate them more
and I guess enjoy them.
- Oh, I love that.
And I'm in the two girls club too.
And I had gotten these little
like stitched needle point,
like football helmet art in
anticipation of having kids.
And I was like, you know what?
The football helmets and
knit are still going up
for the girls.
And now I know that you
love music, Hector, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- And you love a band
called Trivium, right?
Well, we did our research.
We heard you were a fan of Matt Heafy
and we have a little surprise for you.
Take a look.
- Hey Hector, it's Matt Heafy,
singer and guitar player
of the multi-platinum metal band, Trivium.
Drew told me you love blasting our music
while you're out delivering
packages to the community.
So Drew and I got together
to put together a
special surprise for you.
Something a little bit
like this thing right here,
a Gibson Les Paul in Ebony.
This is the one I use.
You're just going to look
pretty much like this.
I've been using these things
for a couple of years,
I hope you love it as much as I do.
Thanks for being a local
community hero, my friend.
Take it away, Drew.
(audience clapping)
- Aw, thank you so much.
- Oh Hector-
- That's awesome.
I love it.
Thank you Drew.
- You know what?
We just led by your example, actually,
you showed us what to do.
- Thank you.
- So thank you for teaching all of us
what kind of human to be on this planet.
And Gayle King said once,
and I heard it while I was pregnant,
and it gave me so much hope,
that our kids will watch what we do,
and that will be a huge
part of how they learn
as kids to our parenting.
And that gave me a lot of relief
because if we behave a certain way,
then maybe our kids will pick up on it.
So you're an example
to your kids and to us,
and thank you, Hector,
for being a local hero.
(audience clapping)
- (laughs) You're welcome.
Thank you so much, Drew.
I appreciate it.
- Now, rock on, Hector.
(inspiring music)